Bonjour à tous.
Alors, ça fait plusieurs fois que je l'évoque sur la chaîne
mais je n'avais jamais eu l'occasion
de faire une vidéo spécifique dessus.
Aujourd'hui on va parler de la mécanique quantique.
Alors, la mécanique quantique qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Et bien, c'est la meilleure théorie
dont on dispose à l'heure actuelle
pour comprendre et expliquer le comportement
de la matière au niveau microscopique.
Microscopique ça veut dire les atomes et puis
tout ce qu'il y a de plus petit que les atomes
et notamment toutes les particules comme
les protons, les électrons, les photons etc...
Donc aujourd'hui je voudrais vous présenter 7 grandes idées
qui sont vraiment au cœur de la mécanique quantique
et dont vous allez voir qu'elles sont
toutes fortement contre-intuitives.
Elles nous montrent que le monde au niveau
microscopique fonctionne d'une manière bien différente
de ce dont on a l'habitude à notre échelle.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La première idée c'est la plus importante
parce que c'est celle dont tout découle,
c'est peut-être aussi la plus choquante.
On l'appelle le principe de superposition.
Alors pour comprendre ce que c'est, on va commencer
par considérer des objets qui sont macroscopiques.
Alors par exemple une balle de tennis ou la lune
ou bien même un grain de sable qui voltige.
Tous ces objets sont trop gros pour obéir
aux lois de la mécanique quantique.
On dit que ce sont des objets classiques.
Si vous considérez un objet classique, comme
par exemple une balle de tennis à un instant donné,
elle a une certaine vitesse et elle se trouve
dans une certaine position de l'espace.
On dit qu'elle est dans un état bien défini.
Et bien ça au niveau quantique, ça n'est plus vrai,
c'est-à-dire que les objets quantiques peuvent être
dans plusieurs états à la fois.
Ça veut dire par exemple qu'un électron peut être à la fois,
ici
et là
ou bien aller, en même temps, à 1000km/s et à 2000km/s.
Un électron peut être dans deux états à la fois.
C'est bizarre, non?
Mais il va falloir vous y habituer parce que
dans le monde quantique, ça se passe comme ça.
Les objets peuvent être dans plusieurs états à la fois,
ils peuvent être dans plusieurs états superposés
et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça le principe de superposition.
Alors, pour faire face à cette possibilité un petit peu bizarre,
les physicien ont été obligés
d'inventer une notation particulière.
On va décrire chaque état entre
une barre et un crochet, comme ça
et donc, par exemple, pour dire que l'électron
va simplement à 1000km/s, on écrit ça
et quand un objet est dans plusieurs états à la fois,
on ajoute les états, on les superpose.
Donc par exemple, pour dire qu'un électron va à la fois
à 1000km/s et à 2000km/s, on écrit ça.
Dans cette histoire on n'est pas du tout obligés
de se limiter à superposer deux états,
on peut en superposer 3, 4, 5 et même une infinité.
Un exemple très classique, c'est que quand un électron
tourne autour d'un proton, dans l'atome d'hydrogène,
il est sur tous les points de son orbite à la fois.
Evidemment, vous voyez à quel point ça contraste
avec ce dont on a l'habitude au niveau macroscopique.
Par exemple, la lune en ce moment est sur un point
de son orbite et pas sur tous les points en même temps.
Heureusement pour nous, toutes ces superpositions
bizarres n'existent qu'au niveau microscopique,
elles n'arrivent jamais à notre échelle.
D'ailleurs c'était pour voir jusqu’où on pouvait pousser
le concept que Schrödinger avait imaginé
son expérience de pensée du chat, vous savez,
le chat qui serait à la fois mort et vivant.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Maintenant que je vous ai expliqué l'idée centrale de la
mécanique quantique qui est celle du principe de superposition,
je vais pouvoir en dérouler toutes
les conséquences bizarres qui en découlent.
La première concerne ce qui se passe
quand on essaye de mesurer les objets quantiques.
Prenons d'abord un objet classique, une balle de tennis,
si je la lance, je peux essayer de mesurer sa vitesse
par exemple en utilisant les espèces de radars qu'on
trouve parfois sur les courts de tennis, dans les tournois.
Maintenant, prenons notre électron qui va
à la fois à 1000km/s et à 2000km/s
et imaginons ce qui se passe si on le fait passer
dans une sorte de radar à électron.
Si on fait ça, à votre avis et qu'on essaye
de mesurer sa vitesse, qu'est ce qu'on va trouver ?
Est-ce qu'on va trouver 1000, est-ce qu'on va trouver 2000,
est-ce qu'on va trouver la moyenne des deux, 1500 ?
Et bien en fait, rien de tout ça exactement.
On va avoir une chance sur deux de trouver 1000
et une chance sur deux de trouver 2000.
En mécanique quantique quand on a des états superposés,
les résultats des mesures dépendent en partie
du hasard, on dit qu'il y a un indéterminisme.
C'est-à-dire que si je refais 100 fois la même expérience
avec un électron exactement dans le même état,
je vais trouver 1000 une cinquantaine de fois
et puis je vais trouver 2000 une cinquantaine de fois.
Cette situation est évidemment totalement
différente de ce qui se passe
avec les objets normaux comme les balles de tennis.
Si vous mesurez 100 fois la même balle de tennis
lancée exactement de la même manière,
vous allez trouver cent fois à peu près la même réponse.
Vous n'allez pas trouver des choses très très différentes
comme ce qu'on pourrait avoir avec des électrons.
Ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ce hasard quantique
est vraiment intrinsèque, fondamental.
C'est par exemple assez différent de ce qui se passe
quand on tire à pile ou face
parce qu'on pourrait dire bah oui, quand on tire
à pile ou face c'est pareil, il y a un indéterminisme,
on ne sait pas à l'avance si on va trouver pile ou face
et on a une chance sur deux de trouver l'un et l'autre.
La différence c'est que si vous tirez cent fois de suite
à pile ou face exactement de la même manière
en lançant la pièce exactement de la même manière,
vous allez trouver cent fois le même résultat.
Et même si vous connaissez exactement
la position de la pièce, sa rotation, sa vitesse, etc...
vous pouvez au moins en principe prédire
sur quel côté elle va tomber.
Ça, en mécanique quantique ce n'est pas possible,
il n'y a aucun moyen de savoir à l'avance
quel va être le résultat de la mesure.
Vous savez peut-être que cette idée de hasard quantique
choquait beaucoup Einstein
qui n'était pas du tout d'accord avec ça
et qui, un jour, avait lancé à Niels Bohr:
Ce à quoi Bohr avait malicieusement répondu:
"Là, il répond rien, je l'ai cassé, j'ai gagné"
Dans l'exemple que je vous ai donné avec mes vitesses
d'électron, on avait des probabilités de 50-50
mais en fait ce n'est pas obligé que ce soit toujours 50-50
parce qu'il y a une chose que je ne vous ai pas dite,
c'est que quand on s'amuse à superposer des états,
on peut le faire avec des proportions,
un peu comme dans un cocktail.
On pourrait imaginer un électron qui soit pour 1/10ème à 1000km/s
et pour 9/10ème à 2000km/s.
Donc si vous avez un électron qui est dans cet état superposé,
si vous essayez de mesurer sa vitesse,
vous allez trouver 2000km/s dans 90% des cas
et 1000 km/s dans 10% des cas.
Depuis le début je vous ai pris l'exemple de la vitesse d'un électron
mais il faut bien voir que ça c'est vrai pour toutes
les propriétés des particules au niveau quantique,
c'est-à-dire que ça pourrait aussi se produire
si on essayait de mesurer la position,
l'énergie ou le spin d'une particule.
En mécanique quantique, c'est intrinsèque, les résultats
des mesures dépendent toujours en partie du hasard.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Continuons avec les conséquences un peu étranges
du principe de superposition sur la mesure.
On va reprendre notre électron qui va
à la fois à 1000km/s et à 2000km/s,
on imagine qu'on le fait passer dans un radar
et imaginons qu'on trouve 1000.
Maintenant, supposez que juste derrière,
je refasse passer cet électron dans un deuxième radar.
A votre avis, qu'est-ce que je vais trouver ?
Est-ce que je vais trouver à nouveau
1000 ou 2000 à une chance sur deux ?
Et bien non, en fait je vais trouver exactement la même
chose que ce que j'avais dans la première mesure.
Si j'avais trouvé 1000, je vais toujours trouver 1000,
si j'avais trouvé 2000, je vais toujours trouver 2000.
A la deuxième mesure, il n'y a plus d'indéterminisme,
c'est comme si la première mesure
avait forcé l'électron à choisir son camp
et à décider à quelle vitesse il allait vraiment.
La manière dont on l'interprète, c'est qu'on dit qu'avant la première
mesure l'électron est dans son état superposé (1000 et 2000)
et que la première mesure le force à aller dans l'état
qui correspond à ce qu'on va mesurer
donc dans ce cas-là, il sera ensuite uniquement dans l'état 1000.
Donc ensuite, quand on essaye de le remesurer avec
un deuxième radar, on trouvera 1000 à tous les coups.
On dit que l'électron n'est plus dans un état superposé,
on dit que son état a été projeté ou réduit.
Ce qui est bizarre dans cette histoire, c'est que
le fait de mesurer la vitesse de l'électron
a, en fait, considérablement affecté son état et c'est
quelque chose de très général en mécanique quantique,
on ne peut pas mesurer les états des objets quantiques
sans les perturber fondamentalement.
C'est évidemment très différent
de ce qu'on a avec notre balle de tennis
puisque quand je mesure la vitesse
d'une balle de tennis avec un radar,
je n'affecte pas tellement la vitesse de la balle de tennis,
je ne vais pas perturber sa trajectoire, ni rien d'autre.
♪ [Générique] ♪
L'idée suivante, c'est l'une des plus connues
et vous allez voir qu'elle découle aussi
naturellement du principe de superposition.
On a dit que l'on avait la possibilité de superposer
deux, trois, quatre et même une infinité d'états
et on a dit qu'on pouvait aussi les superposer
en faisant varier les proportions.
Imaginons un électron qui, pour faire simple, va en ligne droite
puis on va dire que cet électron est à la fois
là...
là
et là,
puis on peut s'amuser à faire varier les proportions
donc on peut dire qu'il est un petit peu plus
au centre que sur les côtés.
On peut pousser le concept plus loin et considérer
un électron qui serait un petit peu partout à la fois
et donc on peut s'amuser à tracer une courbe sur cette ligne
qui représente la proportion de trouver l'électron à cet endroit là
donc on peut imaginer par exemple une courbe
qui décrirait un électron qui serait
un petit peu ici,
puis pas du tout là,
puis à nouveau beaucoup ici,
pas du tout là
et puis un petit peu là.
Cette courbe, on l'appelle la probabilité de présence
parce qu'elle décrit la probabilité de trouver l'électron
sur chacun des endroits de notre ligne.
Alors ça, c'était pour un instant donné.
Maintenant on peut imaginer que quand le temps s'écoule,
cette probabilité va changer, elle va bouger
et donc là vous voyez que ce qu'on a sous les yeux
commence à se comporter pas mal comme
une onde qui se propage, une onde de probabilité
et vous voyez sur cet exemple qu'une particule qu'au départ
on avait envie de décrire comme un objet ponctuel,
finalement on se retrouve à les décrire plutôt par une onde.
Ça c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
tout le temps en mécanique quantique
et qu'on appelle la dualité onde-corpuscule.
Le fait que les objets ponctuels ou qu'on croit ponctuels
se comportent en fait au niveau microscopique
comme des ondes.
Cette idée ne devrait pas vous être totalement étrangère
puisque qu'on sait notamment
que c'est ce qui se passe pour la lumière.
La lumière suivant les circonstances
se comporte comme une particule, le photon
ou bien comme une onde, l'onde électromagnétique.
Le fait que les particules de matière se comportent
comme des ondes a plein de conséquences assez amusantes,
Il y en a une que j'aime bien, c'est que quand
une particule a l'air de se déplacer d'un point à un autre,
en fait, elle fait le déplacement en empruntant
à la fois tous les chemins possibles.
Par exemple, si vous imaginez balancer des balles de tennis
sur un mur dans lequel il y aurait deux fenêtres ouvertes,
vous allez avoir un certain nombre de balles
qui vont toucher le mur
et puis vous allez avoir des balles qui vont passer par
la 1ère fenêtre et des balles qui vont passer par la 2ème.
Maintenant si vous refaites l'expérience avec des électrons,
alors on peut utiliser un canon à électrons, ça existe
et que vous balancez des électrons sur un écran
sur lequel vous avez percé deux trous,
on peut montrer que si un électron passe par l'un des trous,
en fait, il passe aussi un petit peu par l'autre trou.
C'est à dire que l'électron emprunte
à la fois tous les chemins possibles.
Ça c'est une expériences qui est vraiment très intrigante
et dont il faudra que je vous reparle un jour
parce que c'est peut-être une des expérience
les plus spectaculaires et les plus importantes
de la physique du 20ème siècle.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Il y a une autre conséquence très bizarre du comportement
ondulatoire de la matière au niveau microscopique,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet tunnel.
Reprenons nos balles de tennis qu'on balance
et imaginons qu'on les balance cette fois
contre un mur sur lequel il n'y a pas de fenêtre.
Si je balance une balle, elle va rebondir
et si j'en balance 10, 100 ou 1 million, elles vont toutes rebondir.
A votre avis qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
si on fait ça avec des électrons?
Il faut se souvenir qu'un électron, au niveau
microscopique, il est décrit par une onde.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe quand je balance
une onde contre un obstacle?
Vous pouvez penser par exemple aux ondes sonores.
Imaginez, vous êtes chez vous,
vous écoutez de la musique un peu fort...
♪ [Musique heavy metal] ♪
et puis vous avez un mur qui vous sépare de chez le voisin.
L'onde sonore qui arrive sur le mur, qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire?
Elle va être en partie absorbée, en partie réfléchie
et il y en a toujours une toute petite partie
qui va traverser le mur, qui va être transmise
et donc votre voisin va entendre votre musique.
Maintenant, si on transpose ça au cas de l'onde qui décrit
un électron qu'on va balancer contre un obstacle,
ça veut dire qu'il y a une toute petite partie de l'onde
de probabilité qui va être transmise de l'autre côté
et donc ça veut dire qu'il y a une petite probabilité
que l'électron se retrouve de l'autre côté de l'obstacle.
Cette probabilité est généralement faible
mais ça veut dire que
si vous balancez un grand nombre d'électrons contre un obstacle,
de temps en temps, tout se passe comme si,
pour l'un de ces électrons,
il y avait un petit tunnel qui s'ouvrait
dans le mur et le laissait passer
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça l'effet tunnel.
L'effet tunnel c'est par exemple lui qui permet
de comprendre le phénomène de radioactivité.
La radioactivité, c'est le fait qu'un noyau atomique peut
se désintégrer en émettant généralement des particules
et l'émission de cette particule on peut la voir
comme résultant de l'effet tunnel.
Pour comprendre ça il faut imaginer qu'un noyau atomique
c'est tout un tas de protons et de neutrons en tas
qui sont maintenus entre eux
par ce qu'on appelle la force nucléaire forte.
Il faut imaginer que c'est un peu comme s'ils étaient
dans une pièce et qu'ils étaient confinés entre eux comme ça
et puis, ils sont très agités et de temps en temps,
sous l'effet du hasard, il y a un petit groupe de particules
qui peut arriver à s'échapper en franchissant
la barrière par effet tunnel
et donc ça provoque l'émission d'une particule
et c'est ça qu'on appelle la radioactivité.
Il faut savoir que l'effet tunnel a d'autres applications
concrètes et il y en a une qui est assez jolie,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le microscope à effet tunnel.
Le microscope à effet tunnel, c'est le premier
microscope qui a permis dans les années 80, je crois,
de voir pour la première fois les atomes.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Vous voyez sur tous les exemples que j'ai donnés
que, du fait de leur comportement ondulatoire,
les particules quantiques peuvent faire
tout un tas de trucs vachement sympas
que les particules classiques ne peuvent pas faire.
Elles peuvent être à plusieurs endroits à la fois,
elles peuvent passer par tous les chemins en même temps
et elles peuvent même traverser les murs
donc ça a l'air vachement cool d'être une particule quantique.
Sauf que là, on va voir une restriction
qu'elles ont, quand même,
c'est que certaines de leurs propriétés sont quantifiées.
Oui, parce qu'à ce stade, vous vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi la mécanique quantique s'appelle
la mécanique quantique,
d'ailleurs à une certaine époque
on l'appelait plutôt la mécanique ondulatoire
et étant donné ce qu'on vient de voir,
ce n'est pas forcément une mauvaise idée.
Pour comprendre pourquoi la mécanique quantique est quantique,
on va retourner à nouveau à l'exemple d'un objet classique.
On va considérer, par exemple, un satellite en orbite
autour de la terre donc il est sur une certaine orbite,
on peut mesurer le rayon entre
le centre de la terre et l'orbite du satellite
et à partir de ça on peut calculer
tout un tas de choses sur sa trajectoire
et on peut notamment calculer son énergie,
il y a une formule pour ça.
Donc là, j'ai placé mon satellite à une certaine orbite
et donc il a une certaine énergie
mais j'aurais très bien pu le mettre sur une orbite qui était
juste un pouième plus haute ou juste un pouième plus basse.
et si j'avais fait ça, son énergie aurait été juste
un pouième plus élevée ou juste un pouième plus faible
mais il n'y a pas d'énergie interdite ou il n'y a pas d'orbite interdite.
Ça, au niveau microscopique ça ne marche plus,
par exemple, un électron qui tourne autour d'un proton
ne peut pas avoir n'importe quelle énergie,
en fait il n'y a même que quelques
valeurs d'énergie qui sont possibles.
Une manière de l'interpréter c'est de dire que c'est comme
si l'électron n'avait que certaines orbites possibles
et que ça lui soit absolument interdit
d'aller sur les orbites intermédiaires.
Du coup ces orbites, ou plutôt ces niveaux d'énergie,
on leur donne des numéros: 1, 2, 3, 4
et donc le niveau d’énergie le plus faible, c'est le numéro 1
c'est-à-dire que c'est impossible d'avoir
une énergie qui soit plus faible que ça
et ça veut dire d'une certaine manière
que c'est impossible pour l'électron
d'aller sur une orbite qui soit encore plus proche du proton.
Ça, c'est l'illustration du fait que
pour un électron qui tourne autour d'un proton
l'énergie est quantifiée, c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne peut
prendre que certaines valeurs possibles
ce qui est évidemment différent de ce qu'on a
généralement en mécanique classique
où, à priori, toutes les énergies sont possibles,
on peut prendre une énergie de n'importe quelle valeur.
Ce phénomène de quantification
on peut le trouver un petit peu bizarre
mais vous allez voir que c'est finalement
une conséquence assez naturelle du fait qu'on traite
les particules au niveau quantique comme des ondes.
Pour comprendre ça, vous pouvez penser
aux ondulations d'une corde de guitare.
Une corde de guitare, si elle est bien attachée à ses deux extrémités,
elle ne peut vibrer que de certaines manières.
La manière la plus simple, c'est celle-ci, on appelle ça le fondamental,
ça correspond à la fréquence la plus grave possible,
mais elle peut aussi vibrer de cette manière-là
qui correspond à une fréquence deux fois plus élevée
ou celle-ci, trois fois plus élevée, etc...
Pour la corde de guitare, vous voyez qu'il n'y a que
certaines fréquences de vibration qui sont permises
et c'est absolument impossible de la faire vibrer
à des fréquences qui seraient intermédiaires.
On peut dire que les vibrations
de la corde de guitare sont quantifiées.
C'est à peu près pour la même raison que les niveaux
d'énergie de l'atome d'hydrogène sont quantifiés eux
aussi.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La dernière idée que l'on va voir, c'est l'une des plus
connues mais c'est aussi l'une des plus insaisissables,
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg.
Tout à l'heure je vous ai expliqué qu'on pouvait
décrire les objets quantiques par des états
et on peut avoir des états très simples comme
par exemple, la vitesse est égale à 1000km/s
ou bien, la position est égale à 42.
Comme un objet classique est généralement décrit
à la fois par sa vitesse et sa position,
on pourrait se demander s'il était possible
de fabriquer un état quantique
qui soit à la fois une vitesse et une position donnée,
par exemple, X=42 et V=1000.
Et bien non, ce n'est pas possible à cause
du principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg
qui nous dit qu'en mécanique quantique
on ne peut pas avoir un état qui décrive
une particule dont la position et la vitesse
sont toutes les deux parfaitement définies.
Et même, plus vous êtes précis sur la définition de la vitesse
moins vous pouvez l'être sur celle de la position.
En gros, plus on sait à quelle vitesse elle va
et moins on sait où elle est, et réciproquement.
L'exemple extrême, c'est celui par exemple
d'un électron qui irait simplement à 1000km/s
comme on le supposait tout à l'heure
et bien cet électron, ça veut dire qu'il peut se trouver
à peu près n'importe où dans l'espace.
Ce principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg peut sembler
complètement incompréhensible
mais on peut le percevoir en s'en référant
à nouveau aux ondes sonores.
Vous savez que le son est composé de fréquences et
quand vous enregistrez un signal sonore comme celui-ci,
♪ [Accord de piano] ♪
vous voyez généralement l'intensité du son en fonction du temps
mais on peut aussi s'amuser à regarder
sa décomposition en fréquences,
on peut utiliser par exemple un logiciel de traitement du son,
et donc là on peut repérer les fréquences
du Do, du Sol et de leurs harmoniques
qui correspondent aux notes que j'ai jouées dans l'accord.
Il y a une chose que vous pouvez observer
si vous jouez avec ses différentes décompositions,
c'est que plus un son est bref, plus il va contenir de fréquences.
Par exemple, un son de percussion sera très très court
dans le temps mais il sera très étalé en fréquence
et inversement si vous voulez un son qui soit très pur en fréquence,
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne contienne qu'une fréquence ou presque,
ce son devra nécessairement être suffisamment long.
On ne peut pas avoir à la fois un son qui serait
très court dans le temps et très pur en fréquence.
La raison c'est que la durée et la fréquence d'un son
sont deux choses qui sont irrémédiablement liées.
Il se passe exactement la même chose avec la vitesse et la position
des particules qu'on décrit comme des ondes de probabilité.
Comme la position et la vitesse sont un peu
les deux facettes de la même réalité,
on ne peut pas spécifier à la fois
parfaitement la position et la vitesse
de la même manière qu'on ne peut pas avoir un son
qui soit à la fois parfaitement localisé dans le temps
et parfaitement localisé en fréquence.
Si tout ça vous paraît trop compliqué vous pouvez
retenir que le principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg
c'est quand même essentiellement:
"Alors je sais que j'ai garé la voiture mais je ne sais plus où".
Voilà c'était les 7 idées les plus importantes
de la mécanique quantique.
Pour finir, quand même, une remarque qui peut paraître
évidente mais qui mérite quand même d'être faite,
ce que je viens de vous raconter là,
ce n'est pas un cours de mécanique quantique,
je n'ai pas du tout parlé du formalisme, je n'ai pas parlé
des équations et tout ça, c'est juste de la vulgarisation
donc ça veut dire que j'ai été obligé de prendre
des analogies qui sont parfois un peu foireuses,
j'ai été obligé de dire des choses imprécises,
voire des fois des choses qui sont carrément fausses.
Si voulez en savoir plus, j'ai écrit un petit billet sur mon blog
qui précise pas mal de choses que j'ai racontées ici
et je mettrai le lien quelque part.
Voilà, merci d'avoir suivi cette longue vidéo,
si elle vous a plu surtout n'hésitez pas
à la partager avec le monde entier.
Vous pouvez bien sûr vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
vous pouvez me retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux,
Facebook, Twitter.
Ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee
et vous pouvez aussi me retrouver sur mon blog
qui s'appelle Science étonnante.
Merci et à bientôt.